join the party go to
spectator.co.uk and get your first month
absolutely free so peter you've written
a wonderful piece for the christmas
issue this year talking about your first
christmas spent in the ussr in 1990 and
also the last christmas at the uss
arsenal can you tell us about your
experience
well we had to try and make something of
it we were there living in in moscow i
was correspondent time i arrived in the
city in in june
and was living illegally in an
extraordinary flat uh which belonged to
the communist party central committee uh
with the breitner family on the other
side of the courtyard uh but we really
were deprived of an awful lot of things
that you would normally expected at
christmas time we couldn't
we didn't particularly want to import uh
british type food and stuff like that we
were trying to live as far as possible
as if we were genuinely living there
and
all this was mainly down to mrs hitchens
who went out and bought all these
astonishing things for us to eat
including the ingredients of an entirely
soviet christmas pudding
from all the then parts of the of the
soviet empire and the most marvelous
goose
which she found she bought from an old
woman sitting on a corner from whom she
could probably also have bought a bag of
magic beans if she'd asked nicely and
that the resulting christmas dinner
though it was quite complicated eating
it because christmas day
at the western christmas day in moscow
was not at all any kind of feast day and
the the
the congress of people's deputies was
busy meeting in the kremlin and all
kinds of news was happening uh was the
most extraordinary christmas dinner we
ever had and probably the best
so i thought it would be nice to recount
how in the middle of all this uh turmoil
which there was a lot of uh we managed
to have for a few brief hours something
approaching christmas in that extremely
uh intimidating and enormous thrilling
but rather frightening city
it sounds like mrs hitchens very much
saved the occasion there peter but your
seven-year-old daughter didn't seem to
enjoy it as much um you say
she lost her trust in santa claus that
year well she was a bit disappointed
because she put down the usual list of
stuff and i think she she probably
thought being as how we were in a cold
snowy place it would get uh it would get
there quicker and more reliably but the
the presents when she opened them all
had this sort of slightly 1930s look
funny coloured things with dangerous
corners and lumps on them because mr
sitchins had again gone out to the
extraordinary jetski mia the children's
world department store which in those
days stood right next to the kgb
headquarters and bought what she could
but it didn't look like anything she'd
asked for so she immediately realized
that uh that father christmas had let
her down quite badly and obviously this
was a blow
but she had to put up with all that kind
of thing anyway so it was all part of
her growing up that's brilliant um and
robert um you were there in 1973 for
christmas for student exchange so
presumably you didn't have a very
resourceful wife to help you make the
day go well i mean how was it for you
well i was a bachelor
i was in a student hostel in leningrad
and christmas wasn't even recognized
very publicly by the
uh soviet authorities in that period
and it was grim yeah it was a grim time
it was a grim day for a person who
thought it was christmas day to go out
on the street
and
uh not be greeted by someone or not
being
able to greet someone who knew it was
christmas so all of my colleagues
had uh
had gone to moscow for christmas
because i got there not having a visa
until the last moment because i was
studying
uh lenin
uh
and um
so i was marooned there and feeling
pretty sorry for myself
so what did you end up doing all day
i went i i booked up god it was it was
really clunky in those days
to get a
telephone call back to the uk you had to
book it
a month sorry a week beforehand and go
to a
telephone kiosk
bank
in the center of the city
uh where you would um
have a
20-minute slot
uh to talk to your family or
you have to pay for it and so on uh it
was all very
it was it was like going into a hospital
i'm not a very good hospital at that no
did you
i assume you had some cockroaches for
company i mean the kind of place you
put up
they always supplied plenty of
cockroaches in the soviet union for and
and rats as well if you
put cockroaches in there
the cockroaches in the hotels
did you ever get kicked out of hotels
because they had a cockroach day and you
the cockroaches would be fumigated and
then you'd be allowed in
that i had some very weird hotel
experiences in the soviet union but that
wasn't one of them
the the best was of being
was was discovering that my assistant
had been run up all through the night on
the hour every hour by someone from the
kgb posing as a prostitute offering her
services to my female assistant and
she'd said to her in her perfect rush
and look you're ringing the wrong room
it's we've swapped rooms it's my boss
you want a proposition and the woman
said no no no these are my orders i have
to ring this number all night
so she got it well that was that was the
weirdest hotel but uh but never a no
cockroach day plenty of multiple
cockroach days but never a day when they
they claimed to be getting them out
uh and rats as well i mean it was it was
a lot of squalor uh but we were we were
fantastically spared from most of this
because of this extraordinary place we
lived in it it was uh
marvelous of
14-foot ceilings and oak parquet floors
and chandeliers because it we've got it
from a member of the nomin clutura in an
illegal let and the bloc committee had
come around to complain that we were
there and then when they'd seen the
children they'd done that thing which
russians do when they see children and
god completely soft heart and said okay
you can stay
but
that's that's how he managed to hold on
to it but so we were spared an awful lot
of the horrors of soviet life while we
lived in that place it was one of the
nicest places i've ever lived actually
lovely views
river one side kremlin up to the
university the other and uh i'd say the
whole the feeling of being in moscow
very powerful the really big event
was new year's eve when
leonid brezhnev
uh the general secretary of the party
gave um
gave his annual
speech and he
absolutely
ceaselessly
uh burbled on it seemed and and and it
was the the first time that the
soviet
students in the same hostel
started to show some sort of
tittering disrespect for their great uh
their great leader it was so
embarrassing because he couldn't he
couldn't even read read his own speech
and this was in
uh 1973 this was nine years before he
died so
um he was already in a bad way
yeah he was he was a figure of fun for a
long time there was a thing called
soviet rock where people would play the
the 33 rpm records of his speeches and
they pushed them forward with their
fingers to the applause uh and it was a
great joke but it was uh it was a long
and tragic period but he he was gone by
the time we were living in the block but
his family was still there we couldn't
park our car on the on that side of the
courtyard because all these ferocious
grandmas would come out and drive you
away if you came too close the andropov
family also was still there it was uh it
was it was marvelously privileged and
you didn't have any trouble with crime
[Laughter]
well peter actually you know because of
the year that you were there what was
that like as the ussr was disintegrating
around you did it feel like that at the
time
and were you protected from the elements
of the politics side of things we we
didn't know it was going to end so soon
i mean i've gone there obviously to
witness the end of it and to see what
would happen that was the whole idea but
we didn't know how quickly it would come
and we didn't know how it would come and
a lot of very dark things happened after
that christmas anyway a few days later
after christmas i was in vilnius when
the kgb went mad and started massacring
people and and then of course yanaiff
the awful drunk who who'd become vice
president during that christmas uh was
the leader of the putch
which happened in august and i was there
in the same block in august when the
tanks came down the street that we
didn't know how it was going to it was
completely thrilling
it was quite frightening but in in a
sort of controlled way you felt
although you were right on the edges of
european civilization you didn't really
know what sort of government it was it
wasn't that totally alarming thing you
can get in in countries where there is
utter chaos you felt that deep down
underneath
there was a desire for order of some
kind and that you were you were
fundamentally safe i don't think i would
have been able to take children there
otherwise but it was thrilling
exhilarating terrifying uh and i
wouldn't have missed it for the world
robert you were there that year too in
december what was that like would you
agree with peter's analysis
i do indeed i mean it
for
soviet watchers uh it was
thrilling yeah and frightening
uh
at the same time a little
uh memory comes back to me now of going
into one of these big
stores that they had in in
uh
central moscow
in december
1990 and it was a dairy supermarket
and there were
15 or so smartly dressed
uh young women standing behind the
counters
and in this dairy supermarket there was
absolutely not even a half liter of milk
wow and i remember thinking then this
can't
this
this mighty soviet state with all of its
nuclear weapons with all of its
pretensions to summit
uh diplomacy it
it can't last it must be soon on its
knees uh it was a
really dramatic moment for me i remember
that i could buy a little packet of tea
in the dairy supermarket but there's no
butter no yogurt no milk
no all that stuff all that stuff you had
you
if you'd go around the back to the to
the the black the
children you've recorded the black exit
you you would have been able to buy that
stuff or of course do what we did which
was we we
this is without resorting to hard
currency uh if you pay to pay over the
odds and rubles there were very good
markets where as i say we bought the
fantastic ingredients for the christmas
pudding and the wonderful
dried fruits coming up from by the
caspian sea because they were in the
center of this this great empire people
would struggle up
uh with suitcases full of raisins and
whatever it was and sell them for a tiny
profit but people they're fantastically
elaborate black market systems a friend
of mine used to swap uh vodka which she
bought in moscow for chickens which a
friend of hers provided from riga and
she'd put them on the overnight sleeper
and
with a with a fee to the sleeper
attendant and that's how she got her
chickens that's how people were getting
things the shops it's true had nothing
in them but it what was amazing was how
people survived even so uh of course the
system was as you rightly said
collapsing but it the funny thing was in
moscow particularly
there were if you had any kind of money
or contacts you could uh get your way
around a lot of it and the back exit was
crucial to all these things as well and
robert um you and peter have both hinted
at this but the soviet state was not
exactly naturally friendly to the idea
of christmas um can you tell us about
the ways in which um you know the ussr
tried to eradicate these traditions um
throughout its regime
yeah well right from the start it was a
militant
atheistic state so they wanted rid of
religion and they wanted rid of
uh christmas so
uh they
found it impossible to do that i think
they did a survey of the red army
in the second world war 20 years later
and they found that half the soldiers
still believed in god
uh so it wasn't so easy to get rid of
uh christian or muslim or jewish uh
belief
so what they
tended to do was to
have their own ceremonies have their own
rituals and they had one
for granddad frost instead of santa
claus actually lenin had his own
christmas tree you know
uh came from
a lutheran background
originally so he
his family had the sort of german idea
like the british now have
of of the christmas tree
but they never got rid of
never succeeded in getting rid of
the great religious faiths and and it
was
in 1990 going back in the
late 80s and early 90s that that the
soviet authorities finally said
we must have some
degree of religious tolerance and
garbage off
among his
achievements was to impose this on on
a communist party whose members had been
brought up to
to to renounce all all all metaphysical
uh magic as it was called um
so it was a huge huge um huge change
from say 1973
when the the churches were locked up
they were dank they were dreary and
usually it was only old women
who were creeping into them
because they had nothing to lose
young people who did so had everything
to lose they had their whole careers to
lose
well it sounds like an incredibly unique
um experience for for you both to have
had considering that the ussr is no
longer here um peter and robert thank
you so much for joining spectator tv
[Music]
you